there are for all of us dreams on one
side and nightmares on the other
we hope for one and dread the other
frieba rezai has lived both
her original judo training wasn't in
this dojo in vancouver
it was a world away in kabul afghanistan
the goal she set for herself as a young
girl was to reach the top and she did
was one of afghanistan's first female
olympians competing in the 2004 games in
athens
it's a memory that is today
bittersweet
yes i was the first one but i don't want
to be the last one
rizzai lived her dream but the other
side of that is the nightmare she's
living now
watching what's going on in afghanistan
today when the taliban rolled back into
kabul rezai called her family she can't
shake the conversation she had with her
young niece about what could
be coming the first thing that my niece
asked me is
aunt friba
is taliban going to kill us
when they capture us are they going to
kill me because i'm a girl and i went to
school
those were the conversation that i had
with my family members as well as
my other contacts and how do you deal
with that what do you say what do you do
that niece's generation didn't grow up
under the taliban's control
instead it knew freedoms it's a
generation of women that went to school
worked played and never lived hidden
under a burqa
the question is how will that generation
survive
if the taliban takes all of it away
from canada rezai runs a group helping
and training young afghan women she was
able to get a few out before the
evacuation operation was shut down but
dozens more she works with
didn't make it hello
hi
aisha is one of them it's not her real
name we're protecting her identity we
spoke to her from afghanistan where
she's in hiding with rizzay acting as
interpreter aisha is an athlete or she
was the taliban doesn't allow women in
sports
i am
can you imagine a
life
the first time the taliban controlled
afghanistan it turned the country into
what some have called an open-air prison
from 1996 to 2001 the group's extreme
interpretation of sharia law banned
women from public life they weren't to
be seen or heard even their shoes
weren't allowed to make noise there was
no education no social life no
employment
i wish it was just a nightmare
shukria baraksai lived through what she
calls that first taliban darkness and
knew she had to escape the second
when the taliban was out of power barak
zai was part of the afghan government
she was a member of parliament and later
an ambassador barks i was also a
prominent taliban critic and women's
rights activist it made her a target for
years in one attack in 2014 her convoy
was hit by a suicide bomber 30 people
were injured three were killed
when taliban fighters rolled back into
kabul in august barak zai called every
contact she had desperate to get to the
airport and onto a plane
she wasn't alone the chaos and fear was
so much for some they held onto planes
on takeoff and fell to their death
barracks i was on the run these were
images she took trying to stay ahead of
the taliban as it hunted her
she did get out baraksai is now in
london
but for the women still stuck in
afghanistan
she says the darkness
is back
why we should pay the price for the
uneducated group
for uncivilized group
that they are ruling afghanistan
we not select them we didn't choose them
we didn't vote for them
now what will taliban 2.0 look like
among the first things it did was ban
girls from school after grade six order
women who work to stay home women again
have to cover themselves in public and
they can only leave their homes with a
male relative as an escort
its leaders have promised a more
moderate government this time around
[Music]
but the brutality is back including the
public beatings and executions even
hanging bodies displaying them
supposedly as a deterrent to remind
people not to break their laws
fear is a tool and it's being ratcheted
up taliban officials say they're
bringing back amputations the cutting
off of hands and feet for committing a
crime
they are exactly with the same mindset
there's no big difference between
taliban at that time and this time
i don't know why people are asking oh we
should give them time we should give
them time it's more than a month we
should give them time till they destroy
everything and kill everyone
in the first weeks women took to the
streets in protests putting their lives
on the line to push for freedoms
the taliban pushed back at first with
violence journalists were beaten
covering marches
then the taliban banned protests it
didn't approve first
the days since some women who took part
have been hunted down aisha says one of
her neighbors protested and was found by
the taliban and punished
i heard so many horrible things about it
to protect her identity we're calling
this woman lita because of the job she
had the taliban is trying to find her
she's trying to avoid being tortured or
disappearing
they take them away even i heard many
people are just lost and they don't know
their family don't know that where they
are
if they are alive if they're not
now the taliban has promised amnesty to
its former opponents soldiers police
officers government officials it is
already breaking that promise in brutal
ways whether it's been stopping people
at checkpoints or going door to door
they are looking for people and some are
turning up dead
at the beginning they say that we
forgive
everyone
but now we are seeing how they forgave
because that is only a word
how someone can trust them whatever they
are saying it is all fake the world
ignored the taliban's first reign over
afghanistan it controlled the country
with terror and held an iron grip over
every part of a woman's life but until
it affected the west on 9 11 it was left
alone
ignoring the plight of afghans this time
will be harder
this is new afghanistan
says the people of her country have
changed and the main reason is something
coalition forces did help give the
country education
10 times more children were in school
this year than in 2001 20 years ago
fewer than one percent of elementary
school students were girls this year
they were 40
there is a new generation that has now
known freedoms that in the 90s were only
a dream
and they don't want to go back
they want
peace
they want
dignity
they want to be counted as a human
barracks i calls the period between
taliban reigns the blossoming women
became police officers pilots
politicians judges leda was a
photographer she traveled the country it
was dangerous civilians were often
caught in the middle of the conflict at
least 70 000 were killed afghanistan
leda says was far from perfect
but it was
better even in the past 20 years
we didn't have a dream life even at that
time but until we survived still we were
happy people in these countries
we not deserve such a kind of life
honestly nobody deserves such a kind of
life
there is strong criticism of canada and
the nato country's involvement in
afghanistan rivers of money flowed into
the country for years but too often it
didn't reach the people it was supposed
to help and while there was progress in
cities there was almost none in rural
areas there's also criticism of the pull
out how it was executed how after 20
years it left many with a feeling they'd
been promised a brighter future even set
up for one
and then cast aside
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the challenge now is to harness and hold
on to what's left of the legacy of
nato's involvement that new generation
that grew up going to school knowing
freedom is different than the one in the
90s and will be harder for the taliban
to control
my message to afghan women right now is
to stay strong in the last two decades
afghan women had so much achievements so
much gains which we hold very very
precious to us we are not going to let
go of them easily
new technology will help
in the 90s there were underground
schools to educate girls
now instead of in person some of that's
already being done online leta works on
her english with a teacher in calgary
right now it's one of the only things
she can do
only job that i have is
sitting at home and crying for
all the things which i lost
not only me
all afghan women all afghan
people
the taliban's return has meant a new
period of darkness it's made seeing the
light holding on to hope more and more
difficult
the dream of a better future is still
there
but so is the other side
the sort of dream
where you simply wish
you could wake up